[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette émission
spéciale consacrée à la situation en
haïti les funérailles du président
juvénal moïse assassiné le 7 juillet
dernier ont eu lieu aujourd'hui dans la
ville de cap-haïtien des obsèques
nationales qui se sont déroulées ce
matin dans une ambiance dans une
résidence privée de la famille moïse
reportage curling popori qu à
cap-haïtien dans le nord du pays la
famille moïse est chez elle
c'est ici que le président je venais
louise est née
c'est ici qu'il serra intérêt sur le
domaine familial aux côtés de son père
la première dame mme marty moïse a
refusé l'aide financière de l'état
la famille a financé les obsèques du
président avec ses propres fonds
ses funérailles sont presque une affaire
privée
seuls quelques dignitaires ont été
soigneusement sélectionnés ont entouré
des trois enfants du couple martin moïse
a parlé de l'homme avec qui elle a
partagé sa vie ce à quoi je n'étais pas
préparée c'est de me tenir debout
aujourd'hui pour prononcer l'éloge
funèbre de mon mari c'est de me
réveiller un matin et ne de pas et de ne
pas avoir joué à notre rituel matinal
comment accepter de ne plus attendre
d'avoir et rires
de plus d'autres chiffres là c'est mon
droit au sien comment tu imaginé partir
quelque part sans moi jover allen le
fils aîné de la famille a pris la parole
ainsi que la soeur du président
cette dernière a eu du mal à terminer
son discours ils ont tous évoqué la
trahison dont jovenna moïse aurait été
victime
mais personne n'a été identifié à cap
haïtien la famille du président défunt
ainsi que les habitants du grand nom ne
veulent pas que cet assassinat soit
oublié ils réclament tous justice projo
ban à moïse
alors avec nous tout de suite en direct
depuis haïti roberson alphonse
journaliste au journal le nouvelliste
merci d'être avec nous vous avez assisté
à ses funérailles nationales qui était
ont sans doute plein d'émotion est ce
que les choses se sont bien passées à
cap haïtien à cap haïtien avec nous on
est très tendue dans ce matin il fallait
vite valises faire tenter de vous je
vide pour éviter de carcasses de
barricades laissées sur la chaussée la
veille
les rues étaient assez avis quelques
véhicules avec des plaques officielles
et servi de l'état s'il est à vive
allure
on se rendre sur le site où se sont ou
ont été chantées l'intérêt du président
cela s'est déroulé sur fond de tension
il ya eu des tirs des jets de gaz
lacrymogènes lorsque tout autour il ya
eu des gens de deux quartiers bord un
quartier du cap haïtien qui ont régi
fier que le président a obtenu en
justice et ont dénoncé les viandes pas
aux prises comme étant les instigateurs
de tout ça il ya eu barricades de pneus
enflammés tir à certains moments madame
linda thomas grimm trio qui abat saveurs
des états unis à l'onu qui a été envoyé
par le candidat by dell a dû laisser le
podium destiné aux officiels a hissé au
corps diplomatique et nova et spéciale
de login adam à la lime et le lier à
lalime a fait a de même compte tenu de
la situation à volatile c'est ce qui
rend ce soir après les funérailles bien
en ce moment à lyon l'a bien ce soir
depuis cet après midi c'est des rafales
à l'armé automatique 4 à 5 heures de
temps depuis mon hôtel c'est des
accrochages entre manifestants ou de
leurs barricades et à des véhicules des
forces de l'otan un peu une réplique de
ce qui s'était passé hier dans la ville
qu'on a vécu mais un petit peu plus
gravement
si je peux à utiliser
le journal sur quand j'étais très tendu
sur place je vous remercie monsieur
roberson alphonse pour votre
intervention
je venais louise a été tuée le 7 juillet
vers une heure du matin par un commando
lourdement armé son corps a été criblée
de balles
son épouse martine a été blessé au
moment de l'attaqué
sa fille présente également s'était
caché dans une salle de bain je vous
propose de revenir sur ces événements
qui ont endeuillé haïti kelly babeau il
y environ 1h40 du matin à pétion ville
quand le fracas des tirs réveille les
habitants du quartier nous sommes le 7
juillet 2021
ce jour là des hommes lourdement armés
cagoulés pénètrent de façon stratégique
la résidence du président joël moïse
dans cette vidéo postée sur twitter par
un journaliste du irish times on
reconnaît l'entrée de la résidence
présidentielle du quartier pèlerins 5 à
l'origine très sécurisé en légende de ce
poste une phrase édifiante scène depuis
la maison de genel moïse il a été
assassiné quelques heures plus tard un
communiqué de la primature confirme
cette attaque perpétrée par un commando
et le décès du président touché par
balle durant l'assaut vers une heure du
matin dans la nuit du mardi 6 au
mercredi 7 juillet un groupe d'individus
non identifiés dont certains parlaient
en espagnol ont attaqué la résidence
privée du président de la république et
ainsi blessé mortellement le chef de
l'état
la première dame martine moïse est aussi
grièvement blessé par balle mais son
pronostic vital n'est pas engagé 10h30
le premier ministre par intérim claude
joseph
prend la parole dans une adresse à la
nation sur la télévision nationale après
un conseil des ministres spécial
il déclare l'état de siège la stricte
application pratique 59 concessions fait
que cette présidé un conseil ministériel
côté nous décider déclaré état de siège
ce tout pays 13 heures l'arrêté d'état
de siège et 16 jours de deuil national
sont officialisées par une publication
au journal officiel dans le pays où les
tensions sont déjà très vive et où
l'insécurité criante les habitants à ce
moment là sont sous le choc et craignent
surtout le pire qui a tué je venais le
moïse pourquoi et comment les questions
sont nombreuses et l'incompréhension
totale
mais selon toute attente elles vont
commencer à être élucidé plus vite qu'on
ne l'aurait pensé
et nous retrouvons en direct de port au
prince pierre buteau historiens merci
d'être avec nous est-ce que selon vous
cet assassinat était prévisible dans le
contexte actuel en haïti savoir oui
c'est à vous vous êtes à l'antenne
oui oui je pas entendu alors je me suis
demandé est-ce que dans le contexte
actuel en haïti l'assassinât du
président juvénal moïse était prévisible
l'assassinât non pas prévisible mais sa
politique ne pouvait pas aboutir à
quelque chose de concret de sérieux il a
les doigts d'un million son gouvernement
avec mais de là à prévoir un dénouement
paraît aussi tragique
ça nous ça nous dépasse pose c'est après
tout l'opinion publique nationale et
internationale
vraiment et au début on ne sait plus je
crois que jusqu'à présent je n'ai pas et
du modèle c'est que le gouvernement le
gouvernement transitoire qui vient juste
d'être installé et c'était c'est tout
neuf c'était lundi est ce que vous
pensez qu'il est en capacité de pacifier
le pays aujourd'hui je dis tout de suite
non tout de suite non parce que
l'international devra pouvoir de
contrainte
cette solution n'est pas viable cette
solution ne peut pas être viable parce
que cette solution nous éloigne de tout
de tout vers une orientation d'une
politique globale consensuelle et parce
que à l'origine il fallait un consensus
ont construit ce global engageant toutes
les forces sociales et toutes les forces
politiques cantons n'auront quand vous
dites que l'international devra le
comprendre ça veut dire que
l'international est impliqué dans la
formation de ce nouveau gouvernement
visiblement oui il faut logiquement oui
parce que d'abord il ya une première
version et ça démarre aussi que
l'international est ample cirage il ya
une première vers le premier formatage
avec un os avec le premier et et premier
ministre choisit le premier choix plus
exactement monsieur joseph et on a même
évoqué la représentante des nations
unies et ce qu'elle n'avait pas le droit
de s'ingérer comme ça dans les affaires
politiques haïtiennes aussi physique
le mans tout cas c'est pas ça ça ne
remet pas de sa mission et après unis de
ses attributions
alors à partir de ce moment on a évoqué
l'article 149 déjà on arrive et on a
loué un coup à la constitution on a fait
appel à la constitution
mais pour le deuxième forme avec
monsieur ariel henry
il n'y a pas il ya aucune disposition
constitutionnelle juridique dallas dans
cette constitution
il ya aucune disposition et que vous
vous et les îles et ce nouveau
gouvernement transitoire et déjà
illégitime
j'entendrai le fondamentalement
absolument oui ce road la crainte vous
pensez qu'il est en capacité d'organiser
des élections
je le dis très franchement noms tels que
se présente la situation et la situation
avec laquelle il va devoir être
confrontés je crois que ça va être très
difficile
je vois que les américains qui en
principe en se sont substitués et aux
agents des nations unies c'est à dire il
fonctionne comme un pays occupé et à
partir de ce moment comme d'habitude
avec leur pragmatisme tout anglo saxons
il fonce tout droit exige des élections
au mépris même de l'art et les élections
qui vont véritablement avoir du mal à se
mettre en place rapidement je vous
remercie beaucoup monsieur buteau
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
on sait maintenant que malgré ses appels
à l'aide aucun des membres de la
sécurité du président de l'ue a porté
secours
c'est l'une des multiples zones d'ombré
de l'enquêté qui a démarré avec
l'arrestation d'un commando venu de
colombie et qui se perd aujourd'hui dans
des interrogations sans vraies réponses
kelly babeau quelques heures après
l'assassinât
les choses prennent une tournure plutôt
surprenante
l'enquète avance à pas de géant à tel
point que dans l'après-midi des présumés
coupables sont pourchassés et trouver la
police nationale haïtienne déploie ses
forces dans une altercation remet quatre
assaillants sont abattus deux autres
sont arrêtés le lendemain la traque
continue et s'accélère d'heure en heure
de minute en minute
donc comment ces prêts aux urnes après
lot lazio qui tombait le puzzle sur
l'identité du commando avance vite très
vite
le 9 juillet 17 hommes sont fièrement
exposé présenté par la police nationale
haïtienne
il serait selon des autorités les
mercenaires en question
mise en scène de rigueur de quoi montrer
à tous le résultat d'une chasse à
l'homme qui n'aura pas véritablement
traîner une quinzaine d'heures de labeur
l'enquète avance encore et encore cette
fois ci avec l'arrestation et des
auditions des 24 membres de la sécurité
du président vers qui les viseurs sont
désormais braqués des zones d'ombré
subsistent sur cette sécurité
défaillante fbi et interpol viennent
prêter main forte aux services de police
haïtienne
pendant ce temps de nouvelles
informations sur le meurtre sont
dévoilées par le magistrat car laurie
destin nous avons constaté 12 orifices
sur le corps du président le bureau et
la chambre du président ont été saccagés
nous l'avons trouvée allongée sur le dos
pantalon bleu chemise blanche maculée de
sang
aujourd'hui l' enquête révèle que le
président l'homme le plus puissant du
pays s'est visiblement retrouvé esseulé
avec des appels à l'aide
restée sans réponse la fille du
président qui s'était réfugié dans une
des salles de bains et le personnel de
maison qui avaient été ligotés ont
raconté ce qu'ils ont vu et entendu au
petit matin du 7 juillet plus les jours
passent plus on en apprend sur les
détails de cet assassinat mais plus
se demande à qui profite ce crime une
question jusqu alors non élucidés et
nous rejoignons maintenant henri muller
rébus ancien colonel des forces armées
ex secrétaire d'état chargé de la
sécurité
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous alors
vous êtes décrit comme un spécialiste
des questions de sécurité publique
à votre avis est-ce que la sécurité du
président était vraiment assuré il n'y
avait pas un problème de ces pays un
président est libre et livrées le brésil
le président a été pris dans le piège
d'une structure politique utilisera des
bras armés étrangers impliquant
invariablement les américains au premier
chef par ce toutes les personnes qui
sont cités qui ont été arrêtées en
quelques parasites et aux états unis
ils ont eu des séances de formation avec
les américains et se trouve que le
premier témoin de la faire madame with a
été légèrement blessée elle est la
personne qui a dû assister à tout ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'il est à dire
qu'elle a des choses à raconter aux
enquêteurs il n'est visiblement pas
c'est quand même le brisage aux mêmes il
n'a pas été tout simplement abattus
il a été torturé et cela doit avoir du
rire pendant longtemps avant qu'ils
soient eux qui soit fusillés non c'est
une comptine une opération où la
structure de sécurité du président
certes effacer ou permettre la pluie des
assassins du commando à qui profite
directement cet assassinat mais la nasa
comme en revers
la première personne à qui a profité ce
qu'une cette personne aurait fait une
des classes
elle a dit c'est le docteur claude moïse
elle a dit que
je viens de présider un conseil des
ministres
il y a que le président de la république
qui peut plus y d un conseil des
ministres se tiendra vers des cas le
docteur youssef
je viens de présider un conseil des
ministres
donc vous pensez qu'il est derrière cet
assassinat suivant le voeu de l'article
59 de la constitution l'article 59 de la
constitution prévoit que à la quatrième
année que le bis de la rue blais est
rendu indisponible
le premier ministre assure la visite
mais ce début on pensait qu'on aura des
réponses qu'on aura des vrais réponse à
cette enquête sur l'assassinât du
président moïse
absolument pas jamais une billetage en
israël un crime est un crime d'état en
iran peut utiliser l'épouvantail fournir
des explications mais c'est des points
culminants vous ne croyez pas vous ne
croyez pas à l' enquête ni aux résultats
potentiels de l'enquète non ce sont les
gentils ion qui sont à la base de ce qui
est humainement nous avons parlé de la
colombie la renommée est d'impliquer
nous allons parler d'elle avec un gain
de niveau six personnes en haïti en
haïti les gens directement ne sont pas
impliqués c'est uniquement venus de
l'extérieur mais mes yeux qu'il y a des
gens a été imputée et commenceront pour
accéder aux résidents sans que tous les
paliers de son système de c ur des
métiers un seul voeu d'occident d'une à
cette conspiration réalité d'une vaste
consultation interne et xl durable y
aboutir à l'élimination du brésil
merci infiniment pour votre témoignage
dès l'élection de 2015 qui a été annulée
à cause des fraudes puis en 2016 je
venais le mans il a dû faire face à une
opposition forte qui contestaient les
conditions du scrutin où l'abstention
avait été massive
le rendent mieux et devant la nation
d'observer et de faire observer
fidèlement la constitution et les lois
de la république
en prêtant serment ce 7 février 2017
jovenna loïs devenait le 58e président
de la république d'haïti
arrivé en tête d'une première élection
en 2015 annulés à cause de fraudes
massives il est élu au premier tour
un an plus tard au cours d'un scrutin
contesté est marqué par une très forte
abstention inconnu sur la scène
politique jouvenel moïse a été propulsé
au pouvoir par le président sortant
michel martelly qui n'a pas ménagé ses
efforts pour faire élire ce jeune
entrepreneur connu des milieux
économiques par sa réussite dans la
production de bananes moi c'est jouable
et louise nec bonne amie m'a pris un
engagement continu et 10g pays à calais
boehner
ces chemins la vie meilleure mais le
nouveau président contesté dès son
élection aura très peu d'état de grâce
en 2017 de violentes manifestations
agitent port au prince après l'annoncé
d'une hausse des prix des carburants
moins d'un an plus tard la publication
d'un rapport sénatorial sur le
détournement des fonds petrocaribe et
met le feu aux poudres
plusieurs membres des gouvernements
successifs seraient impliqués ainsi que
le président lui-même en novembre 2018
haïti et paralysées par les grèves
l'opposition et la rue demande la
démission du président en haïti
s'enfonce chaque jour dans une grave
crise politique et économique sans
parlement sans pouvoir législatif sans
vote de budgets jouvenel moïse
s'accroche au pouvoir
les élections législatives normalement
prévue en 2018
on était constamment repoussé en janvier
2020 je venais le moïse décide de
gouverner par décret depuis le 7 février
2021 l'opposition le déclare illégitime
car son mandat est arrivé à terme lui
estimé trine jusqu'en février 2022
madame a fini 7 février 2010 mandanne
des commandes à cinq ans
paralysée depuis un an incapable de
trouver une sortie de crise les
institutions haïtiennes auront bien du
mal à organiser la transition et michel
gendre nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
bonsoir michel je vous avais rencontré
plusieurs fois joël moïse ces dernières
années est-ce que sa présidence était
miné d' avance avec une élection aussi
contesté oui effectivement rien n'a été
simple pour ceux 58e président d'haïti
choisi adoubé par michel martelly il a
fait l'objet de désamour dès le départ
et la faible participation à peine 20%
de l'électorat la présidentielle de 2016
ne lui a pas assuré une solide
légitimité
la dernière fois que je les ai vus
c'était il y a deux ans il venait
d'affronter le pays l'homme trois mois
de violences et de paralyser du client
le pays est bloqué pays bloquistes et 3
- du lancer de paralysie il n'avait plus
gouvernement il avait accepté une
interview qui devrait durer quinze
minutes et finalement une des deux
heures avec lui il a parlé parlé j'ai
senti qu'il avait envie de parler de
s'expliquer sur ses actions sur ces
inaction sur son projet de réforme de la
constitution sur ses projets
d'électricité pour le pays qui lui
tenait à coeur il est bâtons dans les
roues tu mettais ceux qui bénéficient de
contrats juteux de l'état ce qu'il
appelle les oligarques corrompu et sa
veuve a dénoncé aujourd'hui une en
intervention dans des cérémonies
j'ai ressenti un homme isolé mais
déterminé dans ses actions fort sans
doute aussi de l'appui de donald trump à
l'époque puisqu'il avait accepté de
renouer de tourner le dos à nicolas
maduro pour enrayer la cause de
l'opposant à quel moment les choses se
sont vraiment dégradé la rue a commencé
à demander son départ de façon de plus
en plus violente
je pense que le catalyseur c'était le
scandale petro caribe quand la société
civile a commencé à demander des comptes
sur l'utilisation des près de quatre
milliards des deux vénézuélienne joël
moïse a préféré faire l'autruche et a
tout fait pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
suite judiciaire à cette affaire d abus
et des irrégularités dans la gestion de
ces fonds ont pourtant été dévoilée dans
les rapports de
parlementaires des rapports de la cour
des comptes des ministres et
fonctionnaires de lancer
d'administration michel martelly et même
j'ai finalement ils ont été étalés dans
ce rapport c'est à ce moment là qu'il ya
eu de grandes mobilisations pour
dénoncer l'impunité et la corruption et
que les positions se sont radicalisées
en réclamant le départ pur et simple du
président pour revenir d'une phrase sur
les circonstances de l'assassinât
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que martin
morizet le seul témoin direct de ce qui
s'est passé elle a commencé à parler
mais sans véritablement nommer des gens
est ce que vous pensez qu'elle va dire
des choses aux enquêteurs
on espère qu'elle dira des choses mais
je doute en tout cas il ya beaucoup de
questions et il me les rébus a souligné
pourquoi la chambre a été mis sens
dessus dessous
comme s'ils ont recherché des documents
et pourquoi plusieurs fractures aux bras
et aux jambes ont été constatées sur le
corps de jouvenel moïse comme s'ils
avaient été torturés là ce sont des non
dits que l'anc est de vous apporter des
réponses et en jouant connaît l'entière
vérité chez moi merci michel merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis je vous
souhaite une très belle soirée sur nos
antennes
bonsoir
[Musique]